kevin is in Texas hi Kevin welcome to
the Dave Ramsey show hey Dave good to
talk to you thanks for taking my call
sure what's up my question is about
buying a house my wife and I are saving
up for a down payment on a home and I've
been listening to you for a little while
but I'm pretty new and I know we are
debt-free and we have a emergency fund
fully funded my question is we both
currently work full-time and so how much
house should I kind of look to buy based
upon our incomes and here's the deal
she's going to graduate school for a
couple years starting in the fall she's
gonna get a counseling degree and
that'll mean our total income will will
drop her a little bit while she's going
to school we're gonna pay for that in
cash but then she's gonna make more
money
most likely obviously nothing's
guaranteed later and so my question is
should we or should we buy a house
according to that 25% rule that you have
off of our current income off of our
income during those two years which is
when we'll buy the house
where she's in school or more along the
lines of a concern an estimate of what
we'll be making together after she
graduates oh probably the middle of
those three which is probably where you
are right now right yeah where she's
about to stop working full-time and work
part-time yeah and so where you are
today if you took 25 percent of that
here's the point of the 25 percent it's
not magic the point is long-term over
the next five or ten years if you have a
house payment that eats up all of your
income you have no money that's how deep
the 25 percent is okay because people
will quote you can get qualified for a
loan that's 50 percent of your take-home
pay and you can't even breathe you can
get qualified for a loan that's 35
percent of your take-home pay easily
easily and then you have trouble funding
your car replacement fund
your 401k your kids college fund because
you become increasingly house poor now
what you're describing is a temporary
situation not a permanent situation so
if someone calls me up in their house
payments 50% of their take-home pay
because one of them just got laid off in
the coronavirus well that's not what
we're talking about
you would just hang on through that cuz
you're gonna get your payback and
afterwards and you're gonna you're gonna
be okay in the house so it's not a it's
not a snapshot of a moment in time it's
the concept that over the scope of the
next decade it's going to be very hard
for you to avoid debt and prosper if
your house payments eating up all of
your income that's really what it comes
down to and so if you kind of said okay
the the the low point of your income is
while she's in grad school
the high point of your income is after
she gets out and the medium point is
kind of where you are right now all I
did was just say hey maybe where you are
right now isn't maybe a good measure of
that it'll be a little bit of a strain
while she's in grad school and then
there'll be almost no strain later when
she gets out and you'll be able to do a
whole bunch of other stuff and you won't
be house poor if you did it based on the
anticipated income basically we're
saying until she gets her new job and
her career blossoms off the new job off
of grad school until then you're
probably not gonna make much progress
financially because you're putting it
all in a house payment that makes sense
yeah makes perfect done so what period
of time do you want to be house poor oh
and how old are you we're about 30 and
how many kids have you got your kids no
kids okay do you plan on having children
yes we will have a couple kids okay we
think the probability as you move yeah
yeah and so I wouldn't spend the next
five years strength I wouldn't spend the
next five years straining on a house
payment based on the income target five
years from now in order to own a house
that I'm probably not gonna live in
after I have kids yeah why strain you
know it's just not it's a temporary
and so you know all that but the whole
point of the whole discussion is if a
big if too big a chunk of your income is
going out the door and house payment you
can't do nothing else your house poor so
if you'll just guard against that you'll
make the right decision okay right and
25% is pretty conservative so if I it's
very I try to keep on track there will
be good even if we end up having a
strain a little bit more exactly those
couple years exactly the 25% is based on
having done budgets for 30 years with
people and I'm saying where you are now
is your projected income today and based
on that we're going to do 25% that gives
you room for kids college fund car
replacement Christmas insurance start
your 401k and baby step four and that
kind of stuff if you get up around 35%
you start to be in a strain you can't
you know you say oh well we'll put this
vacation on a credit card and you start
you start rationalizing your butt off
and start being a normal American again
so that's where it comes from it's it's
conservative unless you're trying to hit
all those baby steps and you don't see
raises thanks for the call